[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence au tout avec le sommaire les
jeudis musicaux de la chapelle royale
ont repris pour une nouvelle saison
jusqu'en juin le centre de musique
baroque de versailles nous replonge au
coeur du xviie siècle le manger local à
l'honneur ce week-end et le week-end
prochain la 3ème édition de goodies line
fait son retour nous parlerons des
différentes animations proposées enfin
partez à la conquête des étoiles la
commande les templiers propose une
exposition sur l'espace jusqu'en
décembre décollage prévu dans cette
émission mais avant de s'envoler pour le
cosmos direction les salles obscures le
festival du film documentaire saint
quentin a débuté ce jeudi pour cette
deuxième édition cinquante projections
et animations sur le thème du sport sont
programmées jusqu'à dimanche dans une
dizaine de lieux hier soir pour
l'inauguration les spectateurs pouvaient
tester à l'ugc de saint quentin en
yvelines le vélo ce mot si les casques
arrêt la réalité virtuelle et assister à
la diffusion d'un film sur le judoka
teddy riner on écoute les organisateurs
de ce festival au micro de michael et
demi d'euros le sport c'est le popu la
population celle au populaire c'est
l'accès du sport pour tous et on veut
montrer à travers le reportage que nous
avons qui sont vraiment éclectique et
qui balaye tous les aspects du sport on
a ce soir par exemple un reportage sur
teddy riner ici mais on aura en clôture
du site du festival à elancourt un seul
un reportage qui s'appelle très en
ovalie qui montre le rugby féminin vous
voyez comme quoi c'est un sport
difficile mais qui peut être pratiqué
par tous l'idée c'est de montrer que le
sport c'est le sport du quotidien le
sport moyens le sport des élites et
qu'en fait c'est d'abord et avant tout
une leçon de vie qui peut s'adresser à
tous globalement on essaie de faire une
sélection qui plaira au plus grand
nombre et qui va répondre et qui va
faire découvrir aussi des sports où on
n'a pas l'habitude de voir en général
les jeudis musicaux de la chapelle
royale ont repris pour une nouvelle
saison chaque jeudi jusqu'en juin des
pages les chantres du centre de musique
baroque de versailles interprète des
oeuvres des xviie et xviiie siècles pour
leur donner une nouvelle vie les murs
chargés d'histoire regardez ce reportage
salle ville les facs boss une messe joué
pour la première fois dans le mur de la
chapelle royale depuis cinq siècles
l'oeuvre illustre le voeu de louis xiii
en 1638 leroy consacre le royaume de
france à la vierge marie louis xiii fils
d'henri iv et père de louis xiv qui a
voué la france à la vierge marie
du jour où il a appris que anne
d'autriche était enceinte d'un futur
dauphin qui allait être louis dieudonné
louis xiv donc il a dédié la france à la
vierge en reconnaissance
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles faire revivre ce
chef-d'oeuvre le concert s'inscrit dans
la programmation des jeudis musicaux un
rendez vous pour faire découvrir le
travail des pages et des chantres de la
maîtrise
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup le fait de chanter les
mêmes champs qui il ya très longtemps
ont été donnés ici dans cette si belle
chapelle par rapport à la musique
d'aujourd'hui c'est une musique très
religieuse très très solennelle
l'auditeur qui vient ici pour la
première fois nous l'invitons vraiment à
voile à voyager dans l'histoire c'est
une façon un peu de faire revivre toutes
ces voix là c'est ses murs en t2 tous
les je dirais tous les fantômes des
chantres et des des pages prochain
voyage la pastorale sur la naissance de
jésus-christ de marc antoine charpentier
le 24 novembre une plongée au coeur du
royaume de france des xviie et xviiie
siècles
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est le lancement de
l'opération good yvelines la gastronomie
est mise à l'honneur ce week-end et le
week-end prochain visites thématiques
cours de cuisine marché de producteurs
locaux de nombreuses animations sont
proposées joséphine coleman bergé vice
présidente du conseil départemental
délégué au tourisme nous en dit plus
on en est à la troisième année c'est une
manifestation qui était mise en place
par le département dans le cadre est
bien de ses actions touristiques
puisqu'il était important que nous nous
centralisons un peu sur la gastronomie
et sur les acteurs locaux et les
producteurs locaux alors c'est ouvert à
tous puisque ce sont des manifestations
qui auront lieu dans plusieurs communes
il ya civils qui sont impactés par cela
et qui nous accompagnent dans le cadre
de marchés dans le cadre de rencontres
d'ateliers et auxquelles les
participants peuvent être le tout à
chacun toutes les personnes qui sont
intéressées par la bonne bouffe si je
peux me permettre à l'ue de ceux de
venir rencontrer les artisans comment ça
se passe en fait l'idée c'est de venir
déguster déjà parce que quand vous
prenez par exemple les manifestations
qui auront lieu le 27 je vous parle déjà
de cette date là eh bien ce sont des
marchés dans lesquels il ya des acteurs
locaux des producteurs locaux on pourra
déguster sur place à chevreuse par
exemple dans le cadre du château de la
madeleine mais aussi le marché de
rambouillet et aussi au niveau du marché
de mantes-la-jolie puisqu'il va y avoir
ce fameux marché autour de la fête de
l'oignon donc il y aura des dégustations
des ateliers et des actions tournées je
dirais sur la connaissance surtout de
nos producteurs qui sont notre richesse
départementale vous l'avez dit c'est une
richesse départemental c'est important
de mettre à l'honneur justement dans le
cadre de cette opération oui aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup des circuits courts et
les circuits courts on le voit se
développe au niveau même des grands
centres commerciaux puisque c'est une
demande de la population pour plein de
raisons pour le respect de la planète
parce qu'on dit qu'aujourd'hui il vaut
mieux ne pas transporter la nourriture
trop loin de consommer sur place et
surtout d'accompagner nos agriculteurs
qui ont véritablement besoin de
seulement d'un coup de projecteur mais
d'un coup de main verte fort niveau de
l'économie les années précédentes ça a
été un succès vous attendiez combien de
participants on a recensé plus de quinze
mille participants sur l'ensemble du
département et des manifestations on
espère sur les deux week-ends avoir à
peu près 3000 personnes qui viendront
fréquenter ces différents lieux qu'ils
sont accompagnés je vous le disais par
les collectivités mais aussi par les
offices de tourisme
on a toute une série de partenaires qui
travaille avec le département le
département aujourd'hui
réfléchit à une nouvelle action forte
sur le tourisme comment ce qu'on
retrouve le programme de toutes ces
manifestations faut aller sur le site
bien sûr du département même sur le site
d'yvelines tourisme puisqu'il ya un site
qui est fortement fréquentés ça prouve
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à apporter à
l'ensemble des habitants et vous aurez
toutes les informations tous les lieux
en tout cas je peux vous dire que j'en
ferais quelques-uns et je vais bien me
régaler
la conquête de l'espace au coeur d'une
exposition à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt l'atelier des
sciences de saint quentin en yvelines
propose de s'intéresser à l'exploration
spatiale jusqu'au 18 décembre direction
les étoiles dans ce reportage
nous 969 le premier homme marche sur la
lune
une date gravée dans l'histoire
aujourd'hui encore la conquête spatiale
susciterait et émotion pour sa première
exposition de la saison l'atelier du
science explorer le cosmos nous avons
travaillé avec différents partenaires du
territoire aussi bien des associations
que des laboratoires mais aussi le musée
de la ville dans cette exposition vous
allez donc découvrir à la fois les
concepts clés et scientifique de la
conquête spatiale de l'exploration
spatiale avec des manipulations
présenter
conçu par le cnes jusqu'au 18 décembre
la chapelle de la commanderie des
templiers se transforme en terrain
d'expérience à découvrir la maquette de
rosetta flottant dans les airs ou encore
ce téléviseur qui ressemblerait presque
à un casque d'astronautes nous avons
dans les collections du musée des objets
sur le design et les modes de vie des
années 60 et 70
ces objets évoque l'espace par leur
forme par leurs matériaux parce que ça
correspond aux premiers pas sur la lune
et donc les designers s'inspirait
beaucoup de ces formes
de l'espace pour pour dessiner les leurs
objets qu'on prend dans la formation des
planètes l'apparition de la vie et
l'évolution de l'univers un moyen
ludique d'avoir la tête dans les étoiles
[Musique]
à dimanche le cabaret du bout des prêts
de cerner la villa propose un spectacle
à la croisée des genres du cabaret aux
airs d'opérette en passant par les
chansons de paris tout cela agrémenté de
costumes chorégraphies et des corps sur
ces images vous pouvez voir la
répétition des musiciens qui
accompagneront les artistes sur scène on
écoute le responsable de la salle il
était au micro de nicolas landry
la particularité c'est qu'effectivement
il mélange l'opérette le classique et le
music hall donc la variété est en fait
c'est une ouverture pour tous les
publics voilà pour mélanger un petit peu
tous les genres alors on peut y
retrouver justement de l'opérette donc
on fait en fait des médias qui rappelle
l'opérette marseillaise
aussi d'autres medley sur des chansons
de paris et puis aussi un hommage au
music hall avec des grandes voix du
moulin que son piano elle joséphine
baker du chevalier
[Applaudissements]
on retrouve mélanie poquet pour notre
rendez vous dédié aux plus jeunes
bonjour mélanie vous avez vous reparlé
ateliers créatifs oui et même arts
plastiques ateliers d'arts plastiques et
plus exactement ceux de l'école
municipale d'elancourt qui donne qui
sont donnés à la ferme du mousseau il
s'agit de développer la créativité des
enfants ils découvrent toutes les
techniques des arts plastiques
l'acrylique de la peinture du fuseau du
fusain ou encore du pastel il travaille
sur plusieurs supports du carton du
papier de la toile ou encore du tissu
alors le samedi matin c'est une session
pour les 7 9 ans et est en bonne âge
pour débuter ce type d'ateliers créatifs
alors fut pas un plasticienne alors le
plus simple pour y répondre c'est
d'écouter floriane fagots elle est
professeur d'arts plastiques pour
l'école municipale
c'est une tranche d'âge qui est la plus
propice pour découvrir encore toutes les
techniques parce que passé un certain
âge 12 13 ans et là on va plutôt être
sûr de l'apprentissage un peu plus
académique poussée des techniques avant
basse ils ont encore cette curiosité ce
plaisir de toucher à tout de vouloir
contester toutes les choses donc c'est
vraiment une tranche d'âge intéressante
alors le jour où nous sommes rendus à un
atelier il faisait du collage il
travaille à partir de papiers de
magazines écoutez les
enfoncer pour faire le ciel comme un
simple
fond ça peut être aussi le fond du mur
sap a dit ce sont des couleurs
et sur ce débat
on fait des motifs quand je serai grande
je voudrais faire râble architectes et
ça m'aide beaucoup là je vais faire mon
fond avec des écritures de papier et
après quand j'aurai tout fini je vais
essayer de faire ma montgolfière avec
les montagnes et tout ça on va en faire
ils choisissent une maison qu'on va
coller tout ça sur une feuille après on
apprendre des trucs pareils comme ça on
va faire un fond d'un dut ni couleur
alors on l'a entendu et ligne vient
juste de parler d'une exposition qu'est
ce que c'est et oui une exposition parce
que depuis ce vendredi les oeuvres
créées par les élèves de l'école
municipale sont à admirer c'est un
résonance un rendez-vous élan courtois
qui a aujourd'hui 25 ans cet artiste
professionnel ont été retenus par la
commune eux ils sont à découvrir à la
ferme du mousseau et les enfants sont
les oeuvres des enfants sont à découvrir
à la médiathèque 17 mars
c'est à découvrir jusqu'au 4 décembre on
écoute laurent majorie le maire adjoint
culture d'elancourt
le thème de l'air que nous allons
traverser et les artistes qui exposent
les artistes nous avons choisi avec ce
jury ce sont des artistes qui en
utilisant toutes les techniques mais
entendu les techniques picturales les
techniques du travail sur le son sur la
lumière sur les volumes sur les
différents éléments vont nous
retranscrire quelle est leur vision de
l'air comment le trop comment le
transporte et oui car on peut
transporter l'air comment le traverse
alors on va terminer avec les
informations un petit peu pratique
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'inscrire à
ces ateliers alors déjà il ya plusieurs
créneaux disponibles les cours d'arts
plastiques se font le mercredi et le
vendredi après midi ou le samedi matin
pour ce qui est de l'âge on peut
commencer dès 4 ans et c'est jusqu'à 18
ans il est aussi des cours adultes vous
pouvez trouver tous les horaires sur le
site de la ville qui s'affiche sur
l'écran les enfants n'ont plus qu'à
laisser libre cours à leur inspiration
et laisse libre cours à leur créativité
également merci beaucoup mélanie poquet
nous a représentés ces ateliers on passe
maintenant à notre agenda les rendez
vous à ne pas manquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux rendez vous à noter dans vos
agendas tout d'abord mardi à l'estaminet
de magny les hameaux organise la
projection est organisée la projection
du film le procès de bobigny la
diffusion servira de support pour un
débat animé par des professionnels sur
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes la gastronomie c'est aussi à
maurepas tout le week-end pour le salon
des vins des saveurs et des couleurs 50
exposants venus des différentes régions
de france feront découvrir leurs
produits les bénéfices seront reversés
aux oeuvres sociales du lion's club
demeure pas un moyen de se régaler tout
en faisant une bonne action c'est la fin
de ce set 8 loisirs merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 10 il a
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]